the Bundys fair is the German military
ready for action in the interview former
German Defense Minister for cover for
Korea Germany has the strongest economy
in Europe Germany is an influential and
important country without a doubt but
when you look at the Armed Forces
there's plenty of evidence that they're
underfunded and under-equipped surely
though Germany needs to have a
world-class fighting force well not work
class but for NATO class when I think
all of the European forces are
underfunded especially the British I'm
in the Army has become very small French
is underfunded spend a lot of money in
the nuclear field so this is the reason
we have 28 armies 27 Navy's 24 Air
Force's a whole lot of money is all so
wasted and so we can't have just one
European army but we don't have any
longer just national armies so division
of labor is the understand what we do
have later well talk about the division
of library a second but I want to come
back to the problems in the Bundys fair
here yeah because you're playing them
down just a little bit I've made a
little list of the problems that the
Bundys fair is facing there's problems
with tanks problems with armored
personnel carriers aircraft flak jackets
night view information equipment there
are even rifles that don't shoot
straight now it would be it would be a
you're laughing it would be a laughing
matter if it weren't a matter of life
and where I would lead a lot of time I
think there are problems the because
also last 20 years we've been on foreign
missions like Afghanistan and everything
was concentrated on that not enough on
the general body but it's also
exaggerated i think in principle the
Bundeswehr still the modern army but you
will concede there are grave problems
it's a it's a modern army there are
problems and they will be solved you
have problems in the other armies also
what I don't like what not agree with is
that the German army is the only Army in
Europe was probably it's still a modern
army and still one of the best armies
later okay breaking a lance for the
Bundys fair there but yeah I believe it
I mean the backdrop to all this is the
tensions we're seeing at the moment in
eastern Ukraine the tensions escalating
fighting there people are very worried
about the sense that there's a new Cold
War you know Russia you know Vladimir
Putin what has gone wrong well first of
all things and Russia have gone wrong I
mean this Putin is no stalin but he's
also know yet seen you know this Yeltsin
has democratized Russia and Putin has
become more and more authoritarian but
on the other hand we have integrated and
given stability two countries of Central
and Eastern Europe but we have not been
able to integrate Russia into a security
architecture which is not the old one so
into a greater Europe and once I hope
the fighting in eastern Ukraine comes
under control we have to work on all
this because you cannot integrate
everybody in Europe and all of the
countries into NATO and EU with the
exception of Russia then you will always
have a problem and on the other hand the
only way for Russia to become a modern
successful state in the 21st century
economically also politically is by
cooperating with Western Europe does
Russia pose a military threat to the
west of course we cannot tolerate what
has happened when you change borders by
force of course they are a threat but I
believe very strongly that Putin knows
the difference within NATO territory and
non-nato territory so i will also object
to those that give you the impression as
if what has happened in Crimea which is
bad enough and what's still happening in
eastern Ukraine which cannot be
tolerated could happen in Poland or in
the body was I saying not the case well
I do not too long ago there was the
German media ran a quote from Vladimir
Putin that he was reported to have made
a statement that he was reported to have
made in a conversation with the
Ukrainian leader Petro poroshenko and it
was the following if I wanted Russian
troops could be not only in Kiev but
also Riga Vilnius
in warsaw and bucharest in two days that
surely that sends a shiver down your
spine no I don't listen to everything
German media report I say that again I'm
sure Russia and the Russian president
knows that NATO territory is sacred and
wherever NATO territory is attacked as
an attacked on NATO as a whole and that
could lead to a really big war and that
is the way to deter war we've done this
in the past we've also do that in the
future okay point taken it's partly in
response to the tensions that we've
already been talking about that NATO and
the EU are beginning to reorganize the
way that they organized their forces
that what we're talking about there is a
division of labor and pooling and
sharing these are very important
concepts I know for you because you've
been involved in this process your other
head of a commission called the Ruhr
Commission what have you come up with I
think we will strengthen the Solidarity
and the Alliance and Germany's rolled in
the Alliance at the same time keep the
role of the German parliament because we
need the Parliament to explain politics
to the public and it was the German
government that twice left a wax in the
past and hopefully after this report
will never leave it in the future
because but at least on the Libya
mission they did so with the backing of
the German people as far as we could
tell know about the backing of the
German people on him the government did
it and the Parliament had no no chance
legally to to change that so what we're
talking about is Germany the German army
has capabilities that we will that we
called composite military capabilities
with a European perspective all of that
there has to be a short availability
when it is necessary and so from the
very beginning and every year the German
government should give a report to the
Parliament look these are not national
capabilities but composite military
capabilities with a European perspective
that need political protection and if
that is done I'm sure German government
and German parliament
will always understand that once they
agree to a mission that these
capabilities which are not purely
national will be made available you talk
about a short availability for some in
the opposition and for some of your
critics you know that sounds like a
blank check don't hand it to the
military that's the opposite of a blank
check when it comes to a mission the
Parliament always have to take decision
but the same Parliament is being
regularly informed about the
capabilities you have to distinguish
between the capabilities and the
government and the Parliament taking
notice these are capabilities which need
political protection which have to be
available in an assured way and when it
comes to a situation I'm sure that both
government and Parliament understand
that this is a difference to other
military capabilities which are not
shared with other nations look division
of labor the Dutch will not have tanks
in the future so they will rely on
German tanks and so there has to be an
assured available this means that
ordinary Germans are going to have to
get used to the idea that they no longer
have a pure National Army yes right and
even the government minister the
government have nun der stood it so for
members of parliament or just the
ordinary to your job you're gonna have
to align it to this one Army in Europe
because there's no European state but we
won't just have national armies but we
have national armies with European
capabilities shared capabilities
composite capabilities which need a
special protection and if that is done
we strengthen the Alliance who
strengthens a solidarity and Germany
will not be the problem of the past and
it will also enable others to go more
along this way of division of labor okay
that was the work of the Ruhr
commissioner my can sense you're very
passionate about it I'd like to move on
to a slightly different slightly
different matter what backing does the
Bundys fair have from the German people
there is a sense that German men and
women in uniform go abroad perhaps come
back traumatized perhaps come back
wounded and then they meet up with
somebody in Germany who says what the
heck were you doing there in the first
place this is this pacifist streak in
German society that is much talked about
what the other side is not in principle
of course our history I mean
makes it more difficult to send soldier
into mission than maybe in other
countries but if we don't want to be a
stumbling block in Europe we have to do
the same things the British the French
and other European nations do there's no
special way for Germany so it has to be
explained in the 90s when the greens and
the Social Democrats were against the
foreign missions which I started in
kampuchea Somalia Bosnia Herzegovina I
told them and can be very immoral to
send soldiers into mission and there are
examples in German history can be very
immoral not to send soldier into
missions when you can stop the killings
of people in bosnia-herzegovina and this
was understood by the population so you
have to explain you the project that I
my senses it sorry too but my sense is
that you've got an awful lot of
explaining to do because there was a
reason there's a recent survey that came
out and you're very well aware of it
there from the the US pew research
center that said that almost sixty
percent of Germans that say that in a
military conflict between Russia and
NATO neighbor Germany should not get
involved well this is you've got a lot
of explaining to do the government does
not do the necessary explaining from the
top to every member of parliament has to
be explained that to defend the freedom
and independence of Germany we have to
defend the Alliance you know this and
this is a well-kept secret you know so
if there would be an attack on the
Alliance German tanks would not defend
Germany at the odor you know this but
they would defend Germany at the borders
of NATO and this is a secret and in some
way the government is not talking about
it which they should because this is why
Germany survived in the past you know
this which is why the tanks from East
Berlin did not move one centimeter into
West Berlin because they were deterred
and we have to deter war from the
borders of the Alliance also with German
troop okay point taken i'm grateful that
you've EU you've made the point i would
like to ask you because you told me
before the interview began that you can
remember the war years is a tiny tiny
boy and the the immediate post-war
period what lesson in a nutshell that
you
from that experience what first of all
Germany never again should be an
aggressor and it has not been but the
second is and we will never do things
just on our own because there might be
the wrong path but I've also learned my
life would have been completely
different if I hadn't lived here under
the protection of NATO to deter the war
and finally it even made the
reunification of Germany father was so
the politicians of today I mean have to
tell people what NATO meant for us in
the past and what NATO means in present
times and in the future not just for
Germany but for the Alliance because if
we allow anybody to attack the Alliance
I don't see that by the way this would
be an attack on Germany and this has to
be explained by our politicians pokhara
thank you very much indeed for talking
to us today